actually I interviewed Bill Bill Gates
uh we had to spend an hour with him in
Seattle
in 2016. um
when he was rolling out his breakthrough
energy thing I got to spend it was 45
minutes me and Bill Gates which was
pretty fun but I I brought this up I
said you know because he's all about the
new nuclear thing that will solve The
World's problems and I yes yes but we
all have nuclear science oh he did oh
sure so he's interested in one of those
oh he's investing heavily in nuclear but
he invests in everything you know he's
got a big portfolio
um
but I brought up a guy I met in India
um
who runs a little outfit called Selco
that they do really interesting cool
Village to Village
they're like an energy analyst will come
to your house here in the states and
tell you how to weatherize your house
but they do it at the Village scale
and in a village that has um
where they're Milling wheat he'll put in
a solar-powered wheat wheat Mill
and
you know that's not going to solve The
World's problems but it gives them a way
to control their energy they don't have
to buy something to grind their wheat
and that needs just as much attention as
the the things I really like too the
cool Technologies and and I I thought I
cornered the gates I was like
because he really does focus on these
big wins the big you know like nuclear
that will make Net Zero completely
doable and I said well you know
what about nuclear like New York City
where I was still living at the time or
near and I said it's got a million
buildings
New York City has one million buildings
and in 2013 the Bloomberg government
analyzed they said looking ahead to 2050
75 of the buildings in New York City
that will exist in 2050 already exist
think about these Brave New Futures
right like we're just gonna come in have
these shiny cool passive house cities
and I so I put this to Bill and I said
so
what's how do you do that how do you how
do you retrofit all those boilers many
of which were coal-fired like 20 years
ago
to get a zero energy New York City and
he I thought I kind of thought I had him
yeah he immediately he kind of sat back
and went well but if you have unlimited
clean power coming into that City it
doesn't really matter
it's a pretty good Bill Gates impression
that's a good answer I mean
I mean he said oh yeah it's a leaky
bucket but you know pour in zero carbon
energy then it doesn't matter
but I still think we have to figure out
the other part too the that end how do
you how do you innovate at the household
level at the Village level
for it's much more of a distributed
problem we used to think the one the one
big change I've had in my own thinking
too is
is from top down to distributed
everything about the climate problem
through the first three decades of my
reporting was that the
the ipcc will come out a new report the
the framework convention the treaty will
get us on board
we'll all behave better this it has this
like top-down you know parent to child
architecture
and everything's I've learned has gone
the other way it's distributed capacity
for improved lives you know kids getting
through school
women not having to spend three hours
collecting firewood and if it means
propane for that household in that
context that's a good thing so stop with
all your yammering about any all fossil
fuel subsidies and
you know what's in America look like
that has some claim
climate safe Energy Future
find your part in that
don't get disempowered by the scale of
it there's just like a thousand things
to do when you start to cut it into
pieces so so it's very different it's
not a top-down thing
you know no one's going to magically
come in and and and that's that's where
I think so I agree that everyone should
try to play their their part and and and
do you know whatever they can uh but I
also think you know just the the sheer
incentives you know what we saw
happening with you know with uh Shale
gas is a great example when Shale gas
becomes so cheap that you just stop
using coal but then you don't really
have to convince you know lots and lots
of people you know it's cold and it
wasn't labeled a climate no it wasn't a
climate thing it was an energy thing it
was totally uh and and and the point is
just you know the power of an innovation
is that you you almost don't see it
anymore it just happens uh and and I
think that's really the only way we're
gonna fix you know these big problems if
you think about you know of the uh
nutrition problem back in the 60s 70s uh
we worried a lot about India and other
places uh solution is not worrying or
the solution was not you know us eating
a little bit less and sending it down to
India wherever the solution was the
Green Revolution right it was the fact
that some scientists made ways to make
every seed produce three times as much
so you could grow three times as much
food on an acre and you know that's what
basically made it possible for India to
go from a basket case to what the
world's leading uh rice exporter uh and
and and that's how you do these things
you know you solve these big problems
true Innovation and again I'm not saying
that you know we're actually arcing our
carbon tax is a smart thing to do you
know that's what any Economist would
tell you to do but it also turns out
that it's partly it's not going to solve
most of the problem and it's incredibly
politically hard to do so it may also
just be the wrong sort of tree to bark
up against you know if you can do it
please do uh but this is not the main
thing that's going to solve climate the
the main thing is that we get these
innovations that basically make green
energy so cheap everyone will just want